each year thousands of new animal
species are identified on December 5th
2016 Emily Ryan age 20 an undeclared
junior at golden Ridge University had a
first-hand encounter with a new species
[Music]
[Music]
scientists at integrase a nearby
discovery phase genetic engineering firm
spliced a helminth parasite with a
horsehair worm and coated in
gene-editing DNA sequences found in an
ancient virus they were trying to create
a non-surgical procedure for eliminating
brain tumors but long story short
someone [ __ ] up this guy Donnie Hicks
if there's one lesson anyone should have
taken away from the 1993 film Jurassic
Park it's that life finds a way or more
specifically life finds a way to kill
you especially when you're messing
around with the genetic engineer and
this is how Emily Rajan came into
contact with a killer brain
the final exam on Friday we're going all
the way back to the beginning of the
semester so study hard good luck and a
fee for the last five days thing do you
want to study later no I'm going over to
Megan's tomorrow the coffee house 9 a.m.
I love it
I'm gonna kill you john-boy yeah fine 11
you better not be late
[Music]
[Music]
sir
[Applause]
come on pick up pick up Emily what's
going on what where are you like I love
Jesus why didn't you answer my texts
Emily
and
are you high
can you let me in
[Music]
Oh what's going on
there's a lesson here somewhere
maybe it's the importance of following
lab procedure maybe is that you should
wear earplugs when you go to bed or
maybe it's that life finds a way to kill
you